[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and tonight Joe
Biden trashing Republicans during a
press conference with Ukrainian
president zalinski all because they are
making border security a top priority
now the president always seems to fly
off the handle when talking about the
GOP while giving America's geopolitical
foes a free pass even as they try to
kill US soldiers abroad almost a 100
attacks in oh a little over a month we
have a full report Straight Ahead
tonight but first the president of harid
is now getting a free pass Claud and gay
just received what is a unanimous vote
of confidence by the University's
governing board after this abhorent
testimony about genocide and virulent
anti-Semitism now festering all over her
campus take a look at this so the answer
is yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the board she said it would
depend on whether uh actions were
associated with it now Claud gay Claud
and gay knows the context a global
antifa is a demand for violence against
Jews the elimination of Israel and when
protesters hold signs that read by any
means necessary they are appraising what
are the barbaric terrorist attacks on
October the 7th and calling for more of
the same now the entire student body at
Harvard they have been harassed by
radical Hamas sympathizers ever since
October the 7th in that terror attack
but Claud in gay didn't seem to care two
days ago up Pen's president resigned in
disgrace after providing a similar
response at that very same Congressional
hearing but at havid their president
will skirt by with a simple apology
claudi and gay is quote sorry if she
offended anyone I don't consider that an
apology anyway go told the uh gay told
the Harvard Crimson that she quote got
caught up and what had be at that point
an extended combative exchange about
policies and procedures not really
according to gay Harvard takes free
speech and free expression very
seriously but in reality in truth well
she is wrong because this year Harvard
was named the worst school when it comes
to freedom of speech in America by
scoring a whopping
0.0 in a study by the foundation for
individual rights and expression now
seven of its professors were discipline
for saying or writing something that the
university deemed offensive one feminist
lecture said Harvard canceled her and
her speech because she does not quote
believe there are male women uh there
are strict rules R against certain types
of speech that are deemed hateful
including discussions that could be
labeled as transphobic or fat phobic
that's right at Harvard apparently now
obesity is off limits but when it comes
to the Jewish people anything goes so
make no mistake Claudine Gay's so-called
apology it was disingenuous but it gets
worse at one point during her apology
all Harvard's president said quote I
fail to convey what is my truth truth
the president of Harvard thinks she owns
a special version of Truth let me see is
it true that uh Israel was a victim of
terrorism is it true that innocent
Israelis was slaughtered and murdered
and raped and some beheaded and some
taken prisoner and kidnapped but of
course her version of the truth is
probably lacking in originality now of
the few academic papers that clauden gay
has actually managed to publish over the
past two decades well now we also know
that many were allegedly plagiarized
that's right the president of what is
supposed to be America's most
prestigious University is an accused uh
plagiar accused of plagiarism on top of
everything else according to the Harvard
Crimson quote the Crimson independently
reviewed the published allegations
though some are minor consisting of
passages that are similar or identical
to gay sources lacking quotation marks
but including citations others are more
substantial including some paragraphs
and sentences nearly identical to other
work and lacking citations and according
to University policy a student at
Harvard could actually be expelled for
such an infraction but not Claudine gay
the president Harvard's board is now
allowing her to go back and amend her
Publications and here's how
congresswoman Alise stonic responded to
this earlier today take a look this is a
moral failure of Harvard's leadership
and higher education leadership at the
highest levels and the only change they
have made to their code of conduct where
they fail to condemn calls for genocide
of the Jewish people the only update to
the code of conduct is to allow a
plagiarist as the president of
Harvard Now by some estimates Harvard
has lost billions of dollars in
donations because of Claudine gay but
the school would rather stand by its
president than admit the moral an
academic rot that is destroying American
colleges and poisoning the minds of
young students hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else